I don't think slow food ever went away
it just was on the fringe I think
everybody remembers Quaker Oats took 45
minutes to an hour to cook if they're my
age and now they take 30 seconds in a
microwave and I think that if that's
particularly right inside of the things
I do because oh it's is oats are a
phenomenal part of the rotations of the
crops we grow but I use that a lot not
because Quaker is evil but because
that's a good representation of how we
saw food move from post-world War two
until the middle 90s and I think that
other people would see it as oh fast
food in fast food chain restaurants and
they tied immediately to food disease
related issues I just see it as a
diminishment of flavor over time I don't
I see these pop and crackle flavors I
was always involved in the food
production industry in hotels and
restaurants so I saw chefs as a rule
abandoning these multi-day stock
reduction systems for cuisine and moving
into systems that didn't require that to
save labor save food cost actually is
more expensive to not make stocks but
they were thinking they were saving food
cost I watched that entire wave happen
while still the classics were being
taught worldwide you know stock is
endemic to civilization it is not
something we thought of to have a fine
French restaurant and as I see the
movement to then step away from trying
to abbreviate things and as I watched
people start to put the moniker together
Carlo Petrini
being I guess the first person that
really popularized the idea it was
actually an outgrowth I think more from
the fact that we didn't want to lose
something than the fact that we were
losing something a lot of people just
assumed that we didn't want to lose
something
whereas my interest in what happened
with the people that did slow food and
became interested in slow food was they
thought they were retrieving something
and the I think deep will to have some
sort of authentic and meaningful
nutrition is really where all this lives
and the word Authentics been beat to
death so I hate to use it so we could
try for something else which would be
there is a certain sort of marker over
time for the kinds of experiences that
gives you sustenance and well-being and
we talked about the idea of slow cooking
capturing that well-being because it
doesn't blow so much out of food when
you don't put fast heat to something
just mechanically there's more there
when you're done cooking then if you try
to cook the same thing and five minutes
versus cooking it in an hour and there's
a lifestyle that goes with that learning
to be conscious well not present that
goes with it and I think that that that
idea then would be it's highly feminine
because it's multi-layered and the
multiphasic individuals on the planet
usually are women that comes to them
naturally man not so much but the idea
then that cooking can become something
you can do many many different things at
once without tending to any one thing at
any one time and I think that is
actually the draw I think people became
bored with the idea that they were
delivered everything and it became they
became just that that's the other thing
that gets me to death we're disconnected
from our foods well we were disconnected
from the process to that the chef's not
doing stock and all that that all came
about with the word instant and I think
that's pretty
pretty much the zeitgeist if it was
instant well you then you say what's
next and if you haven't thought that
through really really well you get
boredom